magic mirror in our hand who's got the
most powerful magic in all the land in
this video we're going to break down all
the magical powers on the Isle and in
auradon watch until the end to find out
who has the most powerful magic in the
entire kingdom and all across the Isle
of the loss Evie Evie doesn't actually
have magical powers but her magic mirror
does we all know from the Disney classic
movie Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs
that the Evil Queen has a magic mirror
every day she asks the mirror magic it
used to respond with the answer that the
Evil Queen is the most beautiful in the
kingdom but then one day it said that
her stepdaughter Snow White was the
fairest of all this made the Queen
insanely jealous
so she set out to destroy her in
descendants the Evil Queen gives Evie
her magic mirror which has been reduced
to the size of a hand mirror she tells
you be to use the mirror to help her and
the other villain kids steal fairy
godmothers wand the mirror still has the
ability to answer questions at first
fans thought the mirror only answered
questions if they were asked in a rhyme
such as Mirror Mirror in my hand who's
the biggest jerk in the land but when
Evie has to answer a tough question in
science class she brings the mirror with
her to the chalkboard she asks a
question that doesn't rhyme and gets an
answer so how will Evie use the magic
mirror for descendants 3 will she use it
to locate Hades or maybe she'll use it
to reflect the evil magic that's being
used to turn everyone to stone back onto
the villain that means that Evie has the
power to turn the villain into stone and
save auradon fairy godmother fairy
godmother has a lot of magical powers
but she needs her magic wand to cast
spells fairy godmothers wand was locked
away in the museum in the first
descendants movie but at the beginning
of the descendant three trailer titled
mouths darkness it appears that the wand
is in fairy godmothers hand when she
walks up behind mal in Bend we know from
the mystery trailer that someone stole
the crown and Maleficent scepter from
the museum if the wand had been in the
museum it could have been stolen too but
there's no mention of the magic wand in
any of the d3 trailers
a fairy godmother has the one she has a
lot of magical powers at her fingertips
one fan theory is that she's the one who
cast the sleep spell on auradon just
like the fairies did in Sleeping Beauty
for more on that theory check out our
video descendants three new theories the
magical powers of the wand allow the
person holding it to do pretty much
anything they want all they have to do
to summon those powers is say the phrase
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo so will fairy
godmother be the one to cast a sleep
spell in descendants three or will her
wand get stolen and used to perform the
Big Sleep
uma uma is the daughter of the powerful
sea witch Ursula since they've been
stuck on the Isle they don't have access
to magic but as we saw it in descendants
to uma can use her sea magic if she gets
past the barrier of the Isle she talks
about being a good swimmer at the
coronation the reason for her superior
swimming abilities is because she has
the power to transform into a sake' lea
a half-human half octopus while in the
water we know from the mystery trailer
that Huma will be transforming into a
Sakuya again in descendant 3 this is a
pretty amazing power
uma is the only villain kid besides mal
to be able to transform into a magical
creature there's one other person who
will transform come the threequel
but we'll get to that later in the video
so back to Emma we know from under the
sea a descendant short story that uma
has her mother's shell necklace dizzy
are you glowing now Olmec in the shell
necklace capture voices but it can also
transform whoever wears the necklace
into what appears to be a different
person
Huma uses the necklace to look like
dizzy in under the sea this is similar
to the time that Ursula used the
necklace to transform into Vanessa and
trick Prince Eric into falling in love
with her in the Little Mermaid it's
highly likely that we'll see Yuma using
the necklace again in descendants 3 dr.
Vasily a doctor facili a is an evil
voodoo doctor from Disney's The Princess
and the Frog
in the movie he sings that he's able to
read a person's future and even change
it he uses his tarot cards to show a
person who they truly want to be and he
can change a person's appearance by
using a talisman with a drop of blood
from the person he wants to impersonate
and let's not forget that he's got
friends on the other side he uses his
influence on the Shadowland to help him
swindle and trick the folks in the
living realm from dr. Fazzio
from what we've gathered after putting
all the pieces together from the d3
trailers dr. faciliate may have Hades
locked up
he has shackles on his ankles so we know
he's been locked up somewhere if dr.
Vasily a was the one to lock up Hades he
must have found a way to be more
powerful than the god of the underworld
which makes him pretty powerful indeed
so when will he make his big appearance
in d3 and how will he use his magical
powers
sylia facili a celia facili a is the
villain kid of dr. facili a looking at
the trailers it's unclear if celia is
evil like her father or if she turned
good like Malin and her isle of misfit
screw in the mystery trailer we hear the
voice of a young girl saying a great
evil will have their revenge and all in
auradon will pay followed by a wicked
laugh they show celia looking rather
menacing so is she good or evil is she
using her tarot cards to predict the
future like her father at the end of the
trailer we see her throw the tarot cards
up in the air the cards fall all around
her as suspenseful music plays in threat
to auradon celia appears to be standing
next to mal as she opens the gate to
hades prison it remains to be seen
whether celia is helping mal or trying
to trick her we know Celia's dad is
very tricky is Celia going to be like
her dad and does she also have shadow
friends on the other side the mystery
trailer makes her look kind of evil but
maybe Disney is just trying to trick us
then one of the most shocking reveals
from The Descendants three trailers is
that Ben transforms into a beast just
like his dad did all those years ago
many fans were wondering if you would
become a beast like his dad but it does
seem rather odd considering his dad only
became a beast because of a curse that
was placed on him by a witch then has
always been a very nice person tomorrow
after the coronation I promise
everything will be okay so who would
curse him to suffer the same hairy fate
as his dad maybe the person who turns
Ben into a beast is the same person who
stole the scepter but we'll get to her
in a minute Ben doesn't really have any
magical powers unless you count the
power of empathy and awesome leadership
qualities but he is the victim of some
magical spell or curse in descendant 3
wait we just had a thought
what if Ben does have the power to
transform himself into a beast at will
could some of his dad's DNA have been
permanently altered when he was turned
into a beast
maybe that DNA made it into Ben maybe
he's got cool werewolf type powers that
he's able to use to fight the evil that
threatens a word on it could happen you
guys I mean anything's possible in d3
Audrey from the mystery trailer and
previously leaked set pictures we're all
pretty sure that audrey has turned evil
and stolen the crown and Maleficent
scepter from the Museum of cultural
history we saw her cackling in the woods
with a terrified Chad charming in the
pictures and we see her silhouette
walking towards a mysterious cottage in
the woods while holding the scepter
Audrey didn't have any magical powers
when we saw her in the first Descendants
movie she seemed a little bitter but
that's not a magical power Grammy I
don't think you want to be talking to
his girl as you feel like taking another
hundred-year now in the mystery trailer
Audrey is shown with light blonde hair
only to be later showcased sleeping in
bed with her grandmother by her side and
Hades looming over her so what kind of
mysterious trouble did Audrey get
herself into we know from Disney's
Maleficent revenge that Maleficent can
use her magic scepter to turn people
into stone
maleficents storms into Prince Philip
and Aurora's anniversary celebration and
curses the whole kingdom turning
everyone into stone so now that audrey
has the scepter it's highly likely that
she's the one with the magical power to
turn all of the people of word on into
stone so will Audrey become a powerful
sorceress in descendants three that
remains to be seen
Hades in DC's Hercules Hades is the blue
flame haired god of the underworld who
is holding a major grudge against the
gods his story sort of parallels
Maleficent
he's all bummed out about not being
included in the celebration of the birth
of Hercules so he summons up the Titans
to take over Mount Olympus and overthrow
Zeus Maleficent in Haiti should start a
support group to talk about their
feelings of rejection anyhow we don't
know much yet about Hades in descendents
3 except that he's been locked up and
that he could be mouths father in the
mystery trailer we see that Hades has a
blue jewel called Hades ember he uses
the jewel to zap the magical beam out
from the hole in the barrier on the Isle
we also know that Hades ember is the
only thing more powerful than Maleficent
scepter so there is a quest to get the
Ember and stop the evil that's turning
everyone to stone our question is does
Hades only have magical powers when he's
in possession of the Ember or can you do
magic the way he did in the hercules
film we'll just have to wait until d3
comes out to see what ATS it's capable
of now now is the daughter of Maleficent
and most likely Hades she has the
ability to cast spells out of her spell
book but her biggest power so far is her
ability to turn into a dragon like her
mom she doesn't even need a scepter to
transform which means she actually
possesses this power that alone is
pretty incredible
but if Hades is really Mouse dad she may
have even more powers from his side that
she hasn't tapped into yet like we said
before it's unclear whether Hades
actually possesses magical powers in the
descendants world or if he needs that
blue ember in order to do magic but if
he does possess powers the way he did in
Hercules then maou is going to be more
amazing than ever in d3 she'll be half
goddess that means she'll probably have
godlike powers imagine a dragon with
godlike powers
she's gonna be unstoppable perhaps
God's status would make her the most
powerful person in all of auradon so
will she use that power for good or will
she always be just a little rotten to
the core
is anyone else bursting with
anticipation to cd3 leave a dragon emoji
in the comments if you can't wait for
the magical three quill and that was
every magical power in descendants three
explains if you love Disney's
descendants as much as we do
be sure to subscribe to our channel to
be the first to see our latest d3 videos
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up thanks for watching the
things we'll catch you next time
[Music]